apple just put out a software update for
their magsafe battery pack yes software
for a battery and it is supposed to fix
one of the biggest issues that i had
with this accessory so today we're going
to talk about the results with this
update and how much faster it charges
going from 5 watts up to 7.5 watts now
and with that do you lose any battery
capacity because of extra thermal loss i
just finished testing and retesting all
of this and if it is now worth it coming
in at 89 instead of 100 when it launched
instead of buying one of these anchor uh
magsafe packs and pretty much my final
thoughts and conclusions after having
this thing for nine months now let's go
ahead and jump right in now the first
thing i want to tell you guys is how to
figure out if yours is updated and if
it's not how do you update it the
easiest way is by attaching it to your
iphone and then going into your settings
app go ahead and hit general and then
about and scroll all the way down where
you will see the maxi battery pack click
into it and you will see the firmware
version now the latest one is two point
seven point b point oh that is the one
that enables the seven and a half watt
charging now if yours does not say that
there are a few ways to update it now uh
the easiest way is just to continue
using it but then in that case apple
says that it could take up to a week for
it to automatically update on its own
through the magsafe connection now the
much faster way is to take it off grab a
usbc to lightning cable and connect it
to your mac which has the latest
software installed or even to an ipad
that has a usb type-c port you plug that
in and wait about 15 minutes and in that
time frame it should automatically
connect update and then you just unhook
it and then connect back on your phone
to verify it or you can go into the
about section go into your devices
select usb and then it will show up
right there with the firmware and with
that out of the way let's get into the
results now this they came out it was a
huge disappointment that even though
it's called magsafe it only gave you 5
watts of charging compared to 15 which
magsafe is designed for now of course
that's because of the low battery
capacity technically it's extremely slow
but because of apple's higher voltage it
actually doubles but it's still nowhere
near one of these anchor battery packs
and i hope that the higher efficiency
would help in terms of speed or capacity
but no it really didn't now with this
update after the first 15 minutes we
reached 12 on our iphone 13 instead of 8
that is 50
faster charging right there so pretty
impressive results right at the get-go
now after a half hour we're at 25
instead of 17. so we're still getting
some pretty good scaling and we're not
seeing any slowdowns from higher heat
you know with the faster charging now
after 45 minutes we reached 37 with the
update compared to 24 before and after
an hour iphone hit almost 50 percent at
49 compared to 32 meaning that we're
getting perfect scaling going from 5
watts to seven and a half in that we are
not really getting any worse efficiency
like we see with some third-party max
save chargers that also run at 7.5 watts
so that is very impressive now before i
give you guys the long-term results and
how long it lasted let me point out that
if you were using a wired charger with
usb type-c to lightning after 30 minutes
of charging you would be at 56
compared to the new 25 with the update
or 17 with the old one so that is a big
gap more than twice as fast as you know
for charging and then after an hour you
could be at 84 instead of 49 or
32 that just shows you how much extra
efficiency and speed you have
charging with the cable and you don't
have to keep it on the back now with
that let's go ahead and move forward
after an hour and 15 minutes we hit 57
compared to 40. so now we're actually
seeing some slow downs because we only
gained eight percentage points in that
15 minutes compared to before we were
gaining 12 and then shortly after this
the battery ended up dying giving us a
total capacity of 60
charge on an iphone 13
taking an hour and 20 minutes now
previously it would actually take us an
hour and 45 minutes to reach 57
charge where now it took us an hour and
15. so this thing literally charged up
the phone had a half hour faster than
before and with that instead of losing
capacity with a faster speeds that we
typically would see the efficiency also
actually increased because we hit 60
charge instead of 57 so that is actually
very impressive that means that apple
fine-tuned you know the charging
mechanism i'm not sure what else they
changed but not only do we get faster
charging speeds we also get higher
capacity so that is excellent so with
these improvements is apple's magsafe
battery pack finally worth purchasing
and the fact that you can buy one for 89
bucks now or should you pick up an
anchor and how has my experience been
well over the last nine months we have
used apple's battery pack even though i
have a lot of others i have the previous
anchor version the black one i have this
newer one that has some extra features i
have some other versions as well and
overall it has been so so i think my
favorite thing about it is just the fact
that it is very nice and slim and when
i'm charging a battery and i'm using a
pack i typically want to throw in my
pocket without having any extra cables
dangle around so it does work pretty
well for that now there have been
multiple times where i was out and i had
it connected and my battery wasn't
charging just because it was too hot
either i'm actually using it
or it's just hot outside like when we
went boating and it just flat out wasn't
charging that has not changed and that
is a bummer and that is where an anchor
will keep charging when you're gaming or
doing something else
now the other nice thing about it and i
think really the biggest selling point
is to use as an actual charger itself
because when you plug a cable into it
and you're using it to pass through
charging to your phone it will actually
output about 12 watts so instead of
buying a puck for 40 bucks for you can
buy one of these for 90 use it at your
desk you know daily to charge up your
phone at night and then when you think
you might need it you could just grab it
unplug and take it with your phone so
that is the nice thing now the other
thing that's really nice about it is
that it also charges up very fast it
takes about an hour and 15 minutes to
charge compared to three hours and 15
minutes for an or either the black
version that you can get for about 42
bucks or this new one so those are the
benefits but that's pretty much where it
stops there's been plenty of times where
i know that i want more capacity for
example we're going camping
and i will take something like an anchor
because it'll give me close to a full
charge or the other biggest downside is
the fact that it does not send power out
of that lightning port so
you just are stuck with wireless
charging which takes longer now it's you
know faster but also it takes up more
energy whereas with one of these anchors
i can easily plug in a cable plug in my
phone and get that much faster charging
with less energy loss with that i also
recharge my apple watch if i bring along
my little minimalistic charger so these
things are a lot more flexible now this
latest one that i bought for 60 bucks a
few months ago it's now selling for uh
70. so they raised the price and it's
still the same speed and everything else
like before but it has this nice little
uh flippable stand thing that is really
convenient if you want to charge and
watch a video
and it's also slimmer as well so is it
worth the extra price compared to the
black one i don't know it's up to you
but this now gives me kind of the
slimness of apple's version
but you also have a lot more flexibility
so personally i think i would not be
buying apples out instead get one of
these new anchors it just does a really
good job for what you would use one of
these for you guys let me know down
below if this is enough of an update to
make you want to buy one of these or use
it or if you just go with something else
click that circle above to subscribe
check out one of those great videos
right over there this has been max and
i'll see you in the next video
[Music]